if you're watching this
I'm dead Batman is dead with so few
words Gotham Knights is instantly
intriguing what does Gotham look like
without its Dark Knight perched over the
rotten City for Batgirl Nightwing Robin
and red hood their Leader's sudden
demise leaves a massive hole in the
heart of Gotham and asks them to step
out from his shadow although the new God
fares well from a narrative standpoint
the gameplay systems built to serve
their 30-hour campaign to reclaim Gotham
let the team down
get on
this isn't an Arkham game though Gotham
Knights does use the Beloved series as
his jumping off point in Gotham City the
bat family will still spend much of
their time swooping down on enemies from
gargoyle's overhead or crawling through
vents to get the drop on baddies who are
feeling empowered by Batman's sudden
departure at first glance this version
of Gotham doesn't seem all that
different from other versions of it or
other open world games for that matter
though it looks the part patrolling the
urban spool is sadly a chore because
Gotham Knight's trade this
action-adventure roots for a loot Focus
brawler the Cadence of action foregoes
compelling storylines that complement
the main campaign for real and
repetitive street brawls that reward you
with crafting resources the game starts
really strong with several authored
story missions that feel nearly as big
and bold as you'd expect given the last
15 years of Gotham set games after their
intro however it settles into
unremarkable and unfulfilling gameplay
Loops driven by awkward games as a
service design principles this is most
evident when completing what the game
calls Knighthood challenges you can't
use any of the characters gliding
abilities until you complete 10
premeditated crimes with each hero these
are merely scattered Street crimes found
around the city and repopulated
constantly to unlock these premeditated
class Street crimes you have to find
Clues by first completing smaller
quicker Street crimes because you'll
quickly want the reward these challenges
Dole out the game soon descends into
hours of completing fourth forgettable
side missions that slightly change the
context of each crime but never really
the actions you perform to stop them it
would genuinely be exhausting to patrol
such a Relentless troubled City each and
every night knowing there's really no
end in sight but that likely wasn't the
intention here and it doesn't make for a
good video game worse once you have
those Knighthood challenges completed
you'll still bump up against these
forgettable side missions frequently
boss storylines are Level gated so you
can't quickly see the end of any
questline and to level up between major
boss missions you'll often be doing more
of these Street crimes meanwhile iconic
characters like the Penguin and Lucius
Fox are made to be nothing more than
immobile Quest givers darling out
missions that are more like basic
challenges to earn a new suit blueprint
or a mess of crafting resources
if you really want to go down this
Rabbit Hole you need to know there's no
coming back from it
becoming Gotham City's watchful
protector should be a meaningful Journey
for the characters and the players
controlling them but it rarely amounts
to feeling like anything more than busy
work there are curiously few big bads in
the game too and they lack the variety
and Ingenuity of past showdowns even in
developer WB Montreal's past bat efforts
aside from the main storyline that
heavily involves the League of Shadows
and the court of owls you'll do battle
with Harley Clayface and Mr Freeze I'd
have less of an issue with this low
number if the actual showdowns were more
diverse or interesting but they each
inevitably devolve into an arena battle
against a damaged spongy villain and
maybe an intermittent horde of goons
like the mission design and writing
combat initially makes a strong
impression by being distinct from
previous Batman games the problem
however is it fails to evolve as time
goes on it swaps out the active counter
heavy model for something more rpg-like
where cooldowns and a momentum meet a
lord over your capabilities and it can
look cool for a while you'll stylishly
take down foes of a few different
classes but rather than Occam's very
defensive minded combat here it's more
about keeping the pressure on and always
hitting something it overrides the
Learned techniques that Batman must have
taught the foursome in the name of being
an RPG that demands 30 enemies who
artificially extend each brawl with
hearty health bars as brawls play out it
also reveals a lack of variety moves
look different for each character to
match their personality but the button
presses you'll perform follow the same
script no matter who you are each
character's unique special moves are the
only thing that really separates the
heroes from each other the court of owls
perhaps the biggest and most beloved new
addition to the Batman Mythos in a long
time fails to live up to the potential
of his comic book Source material in the
comics the core is a creepy ever-present
threat whose existence is Up For Debate
merely Whispering about them could get
you killed or so say the dark nursery
rhymes that element of the villainous
secret society is touched on here but it
all feels like lip service in practice
the court feels like any other faction
of enemies especially when you so often
come across them taking part in Street
crimes thereby totally neglecting the
cabal's most important characteristic
they're working from the Shadows that's
not to say WB Montreal misunderstands
its cast of characters although the
court is narratively fumbled the game's
brightest spot is certainly its foursome
of Heroes Batgirl Red Hood Robin and
Nightwing are handed the keys to the
city without warning and they're not
sure how to fill Batman's Boots the
interactions are very often somber and
serious and help characterize them as
The Grieving unsure group of Orphans
they are Batman meant something
different to each of them and the
writing captures this excellently
leveling up and playing with any of them
unlocks the same skill points for the
others which invites mixing in time with
each of them swapping between characters
doesn't just give you a new skill tree
it gives you a new perspective on this
Larger than Life figure who is now
suddenly an irreversibly absent it lands
as hard as intended and it's compelling
to see them pick up the pieces and grow
together
you could visit them
I could what
he went to yours when
you could visit his grave that growing
together is best done in Co-op where the
game can be played with one other person
this version of Gotham is not its best
rendition but it is massive and benefits
from the basic video game truth that
most everything is better in Co-op
Gotham Knight smartly accounts for Co-Op
play in a number of ways too main story
progress follows the host's lead so
opening the map as either player will
reveal the host's current to-do list
however anything the second player does
carries over into their native save data
including gear they found and even story
missions they've completed you'll always
have the option to skip and get credit
for Missions you've already completed in
Co-op this is a great detail that too
few of these Co-op optional games
Overlook so even though Gotham Knight
isn't a great game in most respects it
does at least reveal a better path
forward for games like it it's too bad
the city isn't more exciting because
with a welcome lack of Co-op tethering
defending Gotham in Co-op could take
place miles apart instead there's little
reason to separate though as peripheral
content is so low that you'll want to
only do what's required of you to unlock
the major next story be and nothing more
there's even a peculiar lack of end game
content normally these loot Centric
games are built on the Long Haul but
here the game has all the markings of a
loot ground with any purpose to perform
it if my gear is good enough to beat the
final boss and it was then what
incentive do I have to keep playing to
improve that gear I suspect the
forthcoming four-player Co-op heroic
assault mode which is launching in late
November may be a better answer to this
question but waiting five weeks to go
back to a game that isn't very good in
the first place isn't in my plans by the
end the project as a whole feels
compromised and instead of feeling like
the triumphant journey of iconic Heroes
the Lasting Impression is one of a
difficult development cycle the sudden
cancellation of the last gen versions
was perhaps the first sign but more
appear as you play this includes a lack
of 60 frames per second support on
consoles frame drops in Solo or
multiplayer and an oddly High number of
hidden loading screens if feels old
already even as it can still look quite
lovely when perched high above the city
as its tireless Guardian under the hood
I suspect the game is chugging along to
make ends meet and it certainly feels
that way to play it Gotham Knight's acts
more as a cautionary tale than the
logical next step for this storied
Universe for a long time no one knew how
to make a compelling Batman game and
then we got four of them in seven years
taking what worked before while seeking
to evolve it is admirable but the
obsession over loot is ill-conceived
cynical and tasteless it feels as though
volume of content is given precedence
over meaningful content and for those
that might enjoy the grind the end
game's absence will be noticeable strong
character work and a well-considered
co-op experience can't save all that
ales Gotham Knights leaving this
experience neither the one fans deserve
nor the one they need right now
[Music]